RONALD SMITH: Well we're
going to talk about El
Nino today.
I've got a PowerPoint
presentation, but before I get
into that, I wanted to give
a bunch of definitions.
So El Nino is a naturally
occurring oscillation in the
Pacific Ocean between two
rather distinct states.
El Nino was defined about 30
or 40 years ago as a state
that the ocean went
into occasionally.
Originally it was defined as a
condition of having warmer
than usual waters in the Eastern
Tropical Pacific, and
low biological productivity.
Those two things were the
original definition.
As we began to study it, we
realized that there are many
other things going on involving
trade wind strength,
Walker circulation,
precipitation patterns.
So now it is-- definition has
broadened to include a number
of related symptoms, and I'll
be discussing those in the
PowerPoint presentation.
Let me go through these
two diagrams to
kind of get it started.
Now, one thing that's most
curious about this is that
these two states can exist
without any external forcing.
It's like one day you wake up
in the morning and you feel
great, another morning you wake
up in the morning you
feel crummy, and there's nothing
external necessarily
that's driving this.
It's just kind of
the way it is.
Well El Nino's not exactly
like that.
There's a lot of physics
involved in it.
But it doesn't seem to be driven
by anything external.
It's not the Sun, it's not the
tilt of the Earth, it's not
some kind of change occurring
by human-induced changes.
It just seems to have periods of
several months when it does
one thing and periods of several
months when it does
something else.
And this will kind of get you
started on the discussion.
So I've got two identical
cross-sections here.
They run West to East through
the Equatorial Pacific Ocean.
So there's Asia on this side,
the Andes in South
America on this side.
The International Date Line
would be somewhere in the
middle that'd be 180 degrees
West or East longitude.
And most of the time you've
got a situation that looks
something like this.
You've got very warm water in
the Western Pacific, warm air
as well, and because of that
you've got a lot of convective
precipitation.
Sometimes this part of the ocean
is called the warm pool.
If you say a warm pool to an
oceanographer or to an
atmospheric scientist, they know
that you're referring, or
they suspect you're referring to
the Western Pacific because
there we get the warmest ocean
temperatures anywhere on the
globe, at least during
this phase of the El
Nino, La Nina cycle.
So this is a warm pool in the
Western Equatorial and
Tropical Pacific.
Lower atmospheric pressure
because the air is warmer, and
because the air is warm it's
less dense, so the pressure
underneath, warmer air is
usually lower pressure.
During those periods of time you
have strong Easterly trade
winds, so I've drawn
them this way.
The trade winds return a loft
in what's called the Walker
circulation.
So remember, the Hadley cell you
would see if I sliced it
this way, across the Equator,
here I'm slicing
it along the Equator.
So we don't see the Hadley
circulation, but we do see
this Walker circulation.
It returns the low level
Easterlies in upper level
Westerlies.
In the Eastern Tropical Pacific
you have generally
higher air pressure.
Cooler ocean waters, and the
cooler waters makes it, at the
surface, makes it easier for
nutrient rich water from below
to mix up to the surface, in
part due to coastal upwelling
that we spoke about last time.
And as a result of that, you
have generally a high
biological productivity during
this phase of the cycle.
So let's say then we go into
an El Nino situation.
Now the word El Nino comes from
the fact that when this
switchover occurs, it usually
occurs in November, December
or January, not too far from
the Christmas season.
The countries along the West
Coast of South America are
generally Catholic in their
religion, and the Christ child
is worshipped.
And the fact that this
switchover, when it occurs,
usually occurred within a few
weeks of Christmastime meant
that it was given the
name El Nino, the
child, the Christ child.
That's where the term
comes from.
So it has kind of everything
reversed.
You've got weaker trade winds,
cooler than usual ocean
temperatures and air
temperatures, higher air
pressures, the Walker
circulation is weakened, I
haven't drawn it here lower
pressure than usual in the
East side of the Pacific.
Along with precipitation
occurring along the coast of
South American near
the Equator.
With the warm water here
you have strongly
stabilized the ocean.
Warm water floating
above cold water.
The nutrients are still down
there below, but they can't
mix to the surface, so you get
a low biological productivity
in that part of the cycle.
Any questions on that?
Yes.
STUDENT: Why does the Walker
Circulation weaken?
PROFESSOR: Well because it's part of this--
the air that goes Westward in
the trade wind has to move
back Eastward.
So that whole circulation is
called the Walker circ--
it's just closing the
cycle on the strong
Easterly trade winds.
But remember, when air in the
Walker circulation reaches
this point and then tries to
descend to match up with this,
that descending air is going to
prevent clouds from forming
here, and that's consistent
with what I've drawn.
And here, when this air has to
ascend to then form the rest
of the Walker circulation, the
ascent occurs in these
convective clouds.
So that's consistent as well.
Then when I've weakened the
Walker circulation, that's
consistent with the
way I've drawn the
clouds there as well.
So there are physical laws
connecting all of
these things together.
But on this diagram, and in
fact, in most of what I'll be
saying today, there's going to
be very little explanation
about why the system would
switch back and forth.
So I'm mostly going to be
talking about what we observe
the atmosphere ocean to do in
this part of the world, how
the various symptoms tie
together physically.
But the scientific community
does not have a clear
understanding of what would
make this system suddenly
switch from one phase
to the other.
So I'm not going to spend a lot
of time dealing with that.
It's kind of one of the
remaining unknowns.
It's not that there hasn't
been work on it, it's not
there hasn't been theories
proposed, but I would say it's
not a solved problem in terms
of what causes the system to
cycle back and forth
like this.
So I'll get in now to the way
some of these things look.
And stop me if you
have questions.
So it's a natural oscillation
in the air-sea state of the
Tropical Pacific Ocean.
I'm going to start out with
a lot of attention
paid to this region.
We described it last time as a
region of coastal upwelling.
And that, indeed, is where the
studies of El Nino began.
That's where it was first
identified, and that's where a
number of the early definitions
come from is the
variability along the Peruvian
Coast there.
And to remind you, a typical
well, this is not necessarily
typical, this is a temperature
anomaly from a year ago, just
about a year ago today these
are what the sea surface
temperature anomalies
look like.
The blue means cooler, so you've
got a cooler water than
usual in the Eastern Tropical
Pacific a year ago.
And which side of the cycle?
Is that El Nino or La Nina?
STUDENT: La Nina.
PROFESSOR: La Nina, right.
So a year ago, there was a La
Nina existing, because you can
identify that immediately
because of the colder than
usual conditions in the sea
surface temperature in the
Eastern Tropical Pacific.
So a year ago there was La Nina,
and near the end of the
presentation I'll bring that
up to date, we'll see what
state the Tropical Pacific
has today.
So here's what you need to
know for terminology.
I wasn't able to get the umlauts
over the n's there.
But El Nino and La Nina, which
are the phases of this
oscillation, the Southern
Oscillation Index is defined
as the pressure difference
between Darwin in Australia,
and Tahiti in the Eastern
Central Pacific Ocean, and
that is a measure of this
pressure oscillation that I
told you about.
So on occasion you'll see
plots of the Southern
Oscillation Index, and
that's the pressure
symptom of this cycle.
The Walker circulation
I've defined.
It's a circulation that occurs
more or less in the plane of
the Equator, taking some of
the trade wind flow and
returning it back to the
East aloft in the upper
troposphere.
In a few minutes I'll show you
the TOA array, which we now
use to monitor El Nino.
It's quite a remarkable set
of instrumentation.
Sea surface temperature we
talked about before, and we've
already defined thermocline
and primary productivity.
I'll be using those terms freely
as we go through the
discussion today.
So be sure you're clear on all
of those terminologies.
So here's a list of some
of the symptoms then.
So during El Nino you've
got reduced biological
productivity in the
Eastern Pacific.
Warm water in the
Weak or reversed trade winds.
Lower pressure in the
Eastern Pacific.
Rain in the East, and as I'll
show you later on, there are
some distant climate anomalies
that are connected with El
Nino, but occur in other parts
of the world as well.
I'll get to that later
in the lecture.
So here's kind of
where it began.
As you saw from the chlorophyll
map, it's a very
highly productive region along
the Peruvian Coast because of
the cold water being brought up
in the Humboldt current or
the Peru current, generally
destabilizing that ocean.
And then the winds, the trade
winds, with the Ekman layer
pumping water offshore causing
coastal upwelling bringing
nutrient rich waters
to the surface.
Well given that then, and
here's an example of a
Peruvian fishing boat
catching anchovies.
Given that understanding, what
would cause such a phenomenon
where the anchovy catch
increased from the '50s up to
the '60s, and then in the early
'70s, especially in
1973, it crashed.
Well this is a buildup
of the fishing fleet.
More and more--more and more
fish, and people, and ships
involved in fishing.
What would cause
a sudden drop?
Two possibilities.
It could be overfishing.
But it turns out later on
this rebounds again.
So it turns out it's
not overfishing.
It was some change in the
natural condition of the
Eastern Tropical Pacific, and
that was the onset of one of
the strongest El Nino
situations.
So it was first defined as
this drop in biological
productivity, which we know
has something to do with
coastal upwelling, the stability
of the ocean
thermocline, and we'll follow
that train of cause and
effect as we go.
Here's the way it's
defined today.
Largely in terms of the surface
temperature of the
Pacific Ocean, and the depth
of the thermocline.
So during La Nina, you have
generally a steeply inclined
thermocline, deeper in the
Western Pacific with lots of
warm water then.
But shallower in the Eastern
Pacific, which means the cold
water is brought up
very close to the
surface, even to the surface.
The normal condition is halfway
in between, and then
the El Nino situation is when
the thermocline is flatter
across the Pacific Ocean.
Remember the Date Line is in
here, so this is 120 East and
this is 80 degrees West.
The Date Line is
somewhere in there.
But this means you've got a big
deep layer of warm water
near the Eastern--
in the Eastern part of the
Tropical Pacific preventing
efficient mixing of nutrient
rich waters to the surface.
So that's the way we envision
this today after 30 or 40
years of study.
And the Walker circulation looks
something like this.
Now, in the normal circulation
you get strong trade winds,
rising motion over the warm
pool, and then a return of air
aloft towards the East
and then sinking.
During the Walker circulation
that is weaker and breaks up
and you get rising motion in
the East. And this may
exaggerate it.
This shows an actual reverse
trade winds.
That isn't always the case.
But at least they are weaker
than they would be during the
typical situation.
So weakened trade winds, and low
pressure and rising motion
in the Eastern Tropical
Pacific.
The ocean surface temperatures
differ dramatically.
Here's an example of a map
derived by satellite using
infrared radiation emitted
from the sea surface to
determine its temperature.
During El Nino, and indeed,
these are anomalies I believe,
rather than absolute
temperatures.
Yeah, but they show this warm
anomaly as much as three or
four degrees warmer than
normal for sea surface
temperature in this coastal
region, and then extending out
along the Equator in the Eastern
Tropical Pacific.
So the temperature differences
are really substantial.
Yes?
STUDENT: What's the difference
between an anomaly and a
normal temperature map?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So what they do is subtract--
for every pixel, they subtract
off a long-term average sea
surface temperature.
So what you end up with is of
course, when you plot, then,
normal conditions, it's a very
small variation because you
subtracted off most of the
normal considerations, most of
the normal pattern.
So what's left allows you to
amplify these changes.
So you just subtract the normal
I think some of the
plots you're working with in
lab this week, some of that
data was given to you in terms
of anomaly, rather than the
actual temperature.
So it's a common trick played by
climatologists to bring out
the differences between
the current state
and the normal state.
It doesn't mean, for example,
that these are the warmest
temperatures in the ocean.
It might still be slightly
warmer over here, but because
that's normally warm that
doesn't show up in this
anomaly map.
I mentioned global impacts.
This is not completely
understood either, but people
have once they understood this
cycle of changing conditions
in the Tropical Pacific, they
tried to then correlate it to
climate in other parts
of the world.
There's been a few rather
well-known papers been
published on this the
last 5 or 10 years.
For example, here's what we
think the El Nino weather
patterns are for the
winter season.
If you have an El Nino in the
particular year in the winter
season, Northern Hemisphere
winter, December, you should
expect to get generally, drier
conditions in through here,
warmer conditions there.
Well that's part of
the definition, I
have that in my diagram.
But elsewhere you can get
anomalies as well.
For example, even here in New
England, you might have a
warmer than typical winter
because of some kind of remote
effect of this El Nino cycle.
In the Pacific Northwest you'd
have warmer conditions, in the
Southern part of the US you'd
have drier conditions.
In the summertime the
relationships work a little
bit different, but they're
shown here.
One of the ways we monitor El
Nino is to keep track of the
ocean surface temperatures in
these four kind of commonly
defined areas.
All the scientists who work on
El Nino agree to monitor these
four temperatures.
Sea surface temperature
in area one,
two, three, and four.
So you'll find plot, for
example, of Nino four or Nino
three, a temperature plotted
as a function of time.
It's right on the Equator.
Usually it goes 5 degrees North
to 5 degrees South, and
that's kind of a commonly
agreed upon way
to monitor El Nino.
And here's how it's done.
So there's a rather remarkable
array of buoys that was put in
a decade or so ago across the
Equator in the Pacific.
Many of these have thermistor
chains that go down into the
ocean a couple hundred meters,
so you can monitor not only
conditions at the surface,
but subsurface
temperatures as well.
That's where that diagram
about the depth of the
thermocline came from, looking
at the thermistor chain data
dangling beneath these buoys.
But you can log in, you can just
go to their website at
anytime day or night and get
current data for what the
ocean is doing in this
part of the world.
So it makes it a very if you've
got a new theory, if
you've got a better theory than
anyone else, you can test
it immediately because this data
is available, not only
historically going back 10
years or so, but it's
available day by day, so you
can test new theories and
maybe make predictions.
So it's become a very kind of
open-ended egalitarian subject
where anybody with a better
idea can put it forward
because the data is there
for anybody to work on.
So here's a couple
of plots then.
One is the ocean temperature
departures for the combination
of Nino three and four.
And then below that is the SOI,
the Southern Oscillation
Index, which is defined as the
pressure difference, it's
Tahiti minus Darwin.
Right, Tahiti is the
Eastward-most station of the
two, and Darwin is, of course,
is in Northern Australia.
So be sure you get the
sign of this right.
So, you know, you wouldn't
expect to find such a tight
relationship between these two
rather different quantities.
One is a sea surface
temperature, one is an
atmospheric pressure.
However there is a relationship
between the two,
and I think let's see
which way it works.
So when the Eastern Tropical
Pacific is warmer, that means
Tahiti has a let's see, which
way does that work.
By the way, this is plotted not
in pressure units, but in
units of standard deviations.
So there's a normal fluctuation
to this pressure
difference.
You compute the standard
deviation and then you mark
whether you are close to
normal relative to one
standard deviation, or one
or two or three standard
deviations away from normal.
So that's the way that is.
That standard deviation, again,
I think is the quantity
you're dealing with
in lab this week.
So generally, when you have
warmer conditions you have
lower pressure in Tahiti
relative to Darwin.
That would make sense because
if there's warmer conditions
in the East, which would be this
condition, with warmer
air aloft hydrostatically,
that would mean lower
atmospheric pressure
beneath it.
So there is a physical law
connecting these two, but
still, it's a bit interesting
that it comes out to be such a
nice relationship.
So where are the El
Nino periods then?
Well one of the most dramatic
ones was in 1973, and that was
the drop I showed
you in the ocean
productivity in that region.
There have been some other since
then, especially 1983,
'84, '87, '88, '92, and then
one in '90 I guess
that would be '98.
And you can spot them either
from the ocean temperature
departures or from that
pressure difference,
East-West, across the
Pacific Ocean.
Questions on this?
So how often does it occur?
Well it's not periodic.
It's not as if you can find
an equal spacing.
If you had to make a guess,
maybe you would say that it's
about every, what, five
to seven years,
something like that.
But it's not periodic, it's not
predictable, and, you know
the first person that comes up
with a really accurate way to
predict El Nino will be rich
and famous, because it's an
unsolved geophysical problem,
but it also has big
implications for the way people
live, for agriculture,
for fishing, and so on.
So it's a big question as to
what causes these changes and
how to predict them
in the future.
No questions on that?
So where are we today?
This is from a week
or so ago in 2011.
Here's a sea surface temperature
map, and a sea
surface temperature anomaly.
So we'll get to address
that question
of map versus anomaly.
So there's the warm pool, and
the temperature is given here
so there's actually temperatures
higher than 28
degrees Celsius in
the warm pool.
Generally, we've got pretty cold
conditions it looks like
here, but what's the anomaly?
Well the anomaly is cold too.
So we are in another
La Nina situation.
Has it been a La Nina ever since
last year at this time?
Well here's a plot of Nino one,
two, three, four, and
then just Nino four, and
look what's happened.
We were in a La Nina
a year ago.
We came out of it during
the summer.
These are anomalies plotted,
SST anomalies for these
regions we defined in here.
And now we've slid
back into it.
So it never was really an
El Nino I would say.
It never got strong enough or
persisted long enough to have
an El Nino.
So it wouldn't--19, sorry, 2010,
2011 would not show up
as a El Nino period.
And now we're solidly back into
a La Nina situation with
cold water in the Eastern
Pacific, high
productivity, and so on.
Questions on how to read
these diagrams?
So I want you to be able to look
at a map like this and
tell what is the state
of the Pacific Ocean.
Yeah, Jordan.
STUDENT: Is the one and two
referring to, like, where the
temperature is--?
PROFESSOR: They just
sum the two together.
They take the let's
go back to that.
They often don't want to
distinguish between the two,
so they'll just sum these
two together.
And sometimes they do that with
three and four, they sum
the two together.
It all depends what kind of
detail you want to have in
your SST description.
STUDENT: I'm sorry, was that 3.4
that, like dotted red and
green thing?
PROFESSOR: Where
am I looking here?
STUDENT: On the previous slide
that you were just on.
Is that 3.4, like the red
and green overlap area?
PROFESSOR: Yeah...maybe that's right.
Maybe that's 3.
you're quite right.
That's not the average
of the two.
That's actually four plus that
little bit of three.
That's correct.
Thanks for spotting that.
I was wrong on that.
Melanie, is that right?
STUDENT: It's half of four
and half of three.
PROFESSOR: Oh, it's half of the two.
Sorry.
So 3.4 is that part of four
and that part of three.
Melanie's our El Nino expert.
So she'll tell me afterwards
all the things
I said wrong today.
Let's see.
OK now, here's another
way to look at it.
I think I've shown you diagram
like this before.
It's called a Hovmuller
diagram.
You take data along the
Equator, and this is a
longitude scale where the Date
Line is right there.
And then you plot sea surface
temperature well this is wind
in this case trade winds,
as a function of time.
So you get a time-distance
diagram.
So at each time you can see what
the strength of the trade
winds were across the
Pacific Ocean.
So these are the trade wind
strengths between
5 North and 5 South.
They are negative because a
positive velocity would be
towards the East, and as you
know, trade winds blow towards
the West. So generally you've
got trade winds all through
this part of the Central
Pacific, and these are the U
anomalies where you subtract
off the normal.
And indeed, what we're finding
there is that we actually have
a bit of a reverse anomaly in
the Eastern Pacific during the
last year or so.
And that is--that's connected
with the La Nina situations
you look at my diagram
over there.
So it's not that the trade winds
reversed, but they're
weaker than normal, at least
in the Eastern Tropical
Pacific, and that gave rise to
the or that was consistent
with the La Nina situation
[Correction: The diagram shows
stronger trades near the
dateline and weaker trades in
the eastern Pacific.
La Nina is consistent with
the former anomaly.].
Now what's going on beneath
the surface in
this month of 2011?
Again, trying to understand how
to understand these maps.
Here is the temperature anomaly
in degrees Celsius for
a few days ago.
From the TAO array.
And there is warmer than usual
ocean water beneath the
surface, but not much of an
anomaly at the surface in the
Western Tropical Pacific.
However, in the Eastern Tropical
Pacific, cold beneath
the surface, but also
at the surface.
And we see it here expressed
in a vertical section where
the thermocline is there
allowing that cold water to
come up to the surface.
And that, again, is consistent
with the La Nina situation
that we saw here with colder
conditions in the Eastern
Tropical Pacific.
So I think that is everything
about El Nino.
And we can stop and discuss
this for a few minutes.
Are there some questions
about El Nino?
Yeah.
STUDENT: So when you say it's
an El Nino time, you're not
talking about the whole year,
you're have to be talking
about-it would be kind of a
specific period of time?
Does it change during--?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, let me be clear on that.
So usually when you start an
El Nino it starts around
Christmastime, but then it could
last a few months or
even a year.
So we would refer to that full
period of time, as long as it
persists, as the
El Nino period.
I think I showed you a case
where it lasted longer than--
for example, well that one there
was really, it extended
about a year and a half.
Whereas that one was really gone
in less than one year.
And this one you had kind of a
weak one, but it persisted
actually for several years.
So this comes back to the
question of predictability.
It's kind of random.
And when you go into a El
Nino, you're not sure if
you're going to come right
back out of it.
It could kind of diddle along
for a while in a weak El Nino
and last a bit longer.
But I'd say more times than not
it's over in about a year.
You come out of that thing
about 12 months after
you went into it.
Does that help, Rachel?
Other questions?
Yes, Victoria.
STUDENT: If it's not an El
Nino, is it always an El
Nino--La Nina?
PROFESSOR: Well so this is confusing.
The terminology has changed
a bit on this.
Originally, there was normal
and there was El Nino.
Those were the two
things we heard
scientists talking about.
Some clever individual decided
that they should think of this
as really a yin/yang situation
where it was one thing or
another, rather than normal.
So if you're going to come up
with something that's the
opposite of El Nino, well it's
going to be La Nina.
I don't like it myself, but now
it's already embedded in
the literature as being kind of
the opposite extreme with a
range of normal in between.
So current terminology
would be El Nino--
well, it's here--
El Nino, normal if you're,
say, within one standard
deviation or so of this.
And then La Nina you're down
in the other extreme.
So if you read the literature
over the years, you see that
terminology shift
a little bit.
But don't be confused
about it.
In the old days, everything like
this was normal and that
was El Nino.
Today it's El Nino, a range of
normal, and then La Nina out
the other side.
Yes.
STUDENT: When you showed us the
trade winds diagram and
the anomalies, didn't you say
that when they had strong
winds it was a El Nino?
But what you drew is--?
PROFESSOR: Let's go back and check that because I
may have misspoken.
So what I'm claiming over here
is that the La Nina, this
normal situation with
colder water, has a
stronger trade winds.
And--yeah, maybe that
was opposite--
let's go back and look at
that diagram and see
if I have that right.
Thanks for pointing that out.
Let's see, that diagram was--
yeah.
My computer has locked here.
Here, was it?
Yeah.
Yeah, so it may be I put the
emphasis on the Eastern part,
maybe I shouldn't
have done that.
We expect that during a La Nina
situation we have strong
trade winds.
And that would probably
correspond to this.
This is the anomaly.
So over the Central Pacific not
the Eastern Pacific over
the Central Pacific
we had stronger
than usual trade winds.
STUDENT: So that's stronger,
the negative?
PROFESSOR: Negative would be
remember, trade winds
are from East to West. So when
you see a negative anomaly in
a region which is normally
negative, that means it's a
stronger Easterly wind.
STUDENT: Is it measuring
wind speek, or--?
PROFESSOR: No, it's
not--it's U, it's the
East-West components
of the wind.
Remember when you did the
balloon lab and you plotted up
the data from your pilot
balloon, you plotted U, which
was positive towards, with the
wind toward the East, negative
towards the West. It's
that convention
that we're using here.
You can be sure of that because
this is the normal
situation and those numbers are
negative, indicating that
that's an Easterly wind blowing
towards the West.
That's the negative sense of
this quantity U that I'm
discussing.
Yes.
STUDENT: Where are the
hectoPascals coming from?
Is that what hPa stands for?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's a pressure unit.
They're referring to the level
at which this is measured.
So this is at the--this is
not at the sea surface.
This is the 850 hectoPascal
level, which is about a
kilometer and a half above
the ocean surface.
Remember again, when you're
doing the balloon lab and you
plotted things with altitude,
very often atmospheric
scientists use pressure as their
indication of how high
you are in the atmosphere.
So this is data not at the sea
surface, but about 1,500
meters above the sea surface, at
the 850 hectoPascal level.
Good question.
Yeah.
STUDENT: What is this
map called again?
PROFESSOR: Well it's
called a Hovmuller diagram.
H-O-V-M-U-L-L-E-R. Hovmuller
diagram.
And it's used commonly in
atmospheric and oceanic sciences.
Whenever you want to see
how data along a
line varies with time.
So it wouldn't always have
to be longitude.
You could construct
some other line.
But in this case, they've chosen
East-West as their
linear dimension, and
then time going up
as their time dimension.
Other questions on this?
Yes.
STUDENT: Would you go over
why it's negative?
PROFESSOR: Why these
numbers are negative?
The convention is for this
quantity U, it's positive when
the wind blows toward the East,
and negative when it
blows towards the West. You do
see a little bit of positive
wind near the edges.
But over the vast majority of
the Central Tropical Pacific
you have the trade winds, and
that is a wind that blows from
East to West. We call them
Easterlies because of where
they're blowing from, and with
this U convention that's a
negative on the sign
convention.
I'm glad you asked that because
this is confusing with
those signs there.
Other questions on
these diagrams?
STUDENT: And the one to the
right is during an El Nino?
PROFESSOR: Well the one on the
right is the anomaly.
So what they've done is taken
this data and subtracted off
the normal, the long-term
average, to get an anomaly.
So when you find a positive
anomaly, that would be a
weaker trade wind.
It's only two meters
per second where
this was six and eight.
So what that's going to do is
basically drop the strength of
the trade winds by a couple of
meters per second, but keep
them going towards the West.
STUDENT: So those values are the
actual speed or are they
the difference from
the average?
PROFESSOR: They are
the difference, they are the
actual minus the average.
I haven't shown you the average
here, but these
numbers are this number minus
whatever is the normal wind at
that--at each location.
Anything else on El Nino?
So I think we have
a few minutes to
start the next subject.
Let me find this--
We won't get very
far into this.
The subject which comes next
in the course is ice.
So it's a little odd because
we're jumping from El Nino,
which is primarily a Tropical
phenomenon, to the study of
ice in the climate system,
which is primarily a high
latitude subject.
But they're both very important
in the way the
atmosphere and the ocean work
to form our climate.
I wanted to first just run
through a set of definitions
for the different types of ice
that we'll be interested in.
Sea ice is frozen seawater,
where you take seawater, you
blow cold wind over it, you draw
the heat out of it, you
bring it down to the freezing
point, and then
eventually you freeze it.
That is sea ice.
Ice sheets, like Greenland and
Antarctica, are large plateaus
of ice formed from
compacted snow.
Snow that fell month after
month, year after year, piled
up, squeezed, compressed
to form ice.
So the origins of these
two things are
almost completely different.
In one case you freeze seawater,
the other case you
just compact snow.
Glaciers are streams
of moving ice.
They're moving under the
influence of gravity.
So normally if you've got a
snow fall on the top of a
mountain that builds up, after
a while it gets deep enough,
it begins to be pulled
gravitational down the slopes
of the mountain.
Ice shelves are fixed,
floating ice sheets.
They're basically ice that's
come off an ice sheet, flowed
down to sea level in a glacier,
and then has spread
out over the ocean surface
still fixed to the land.
I'll show you diagrams
of all of these.
Icebergs, I'm sure you
know that one.
Those are chunks of drifting,
floating ice broken off from
glaciers or ice shelves.
And then, of course, on land,
you can have permanent or
seasonal snow fields, just
areas that have received
either just snow for that winter
and it's going to melt
off the next summer, or snow
that is able to persist over
the summer season and still be
there the next year would be
called a permanent snow field.
So these are important terms
in the descriptions I'll be
going through mostly
next time.
These are equally important.
These are the physical
properties of ice that we'll
need to know in order to
understand the way ice works
in the climate system.
First of all, there's
this latent heat
of melting or freezing.
You can look it up,
you can Google it.
The value is 334,000 Joules
per kilogram.
Every time you take water and
freeze it, you have to remove
that much heat.
And every time you take ice and
melt it, you have to put
that same amount of
heat back in.
So it's a reversible process.
That number applies to either
melting or freezing.
And you can do that in
a variety of ways.
You can radiate that heat away,
you can have cold winds
or warm winds, provide that
heat, or remove that heat.
But in any case, whenever you're
melting or creating
ice, you've got to deal with
that amount of heat.
It's a large number.
It's not as large as the latent
heat of condensation.
Remember, the latent heat of
condensation was many times
that number.
You might want to look back and
see what that number was.
This is still big, but it's not
as big as a number needed
to condense water or
to evaporate water.
I want to remind you also that
while the freezing point of
fresh water is zero degrees
Celsius in fact, that's the
basis on which the Celsius
scale is defined for salt
water with a salinity of
approximately 35 parts per
thousand, that freezing point
is depressed to about minus
two Celsius.
You'd have to cool the water a
bit colder if it's sea water
before it'll start to freeze.
This third bullet, I'm sure you
know this, but I want to
impress on you how
remarkable it is.
Most objects, most materials,
when you freeze them from the
liquid they reduce
their volume.
That is, they become
more dense.
Almost every subject known
to man does that.
Water is one of the very few
exceptions that when you
freeze it it actually expands.
I think the only other
one that I know that
does this is bismuth.
Bismuth has that same property
of water as when you condense
it from the liquid to the solid
it actually expands.
Now you know this, because if
you leave a bottle of water
out on a cold night and it
freezes, it'll expand and
break the jar.
So you know it's expanding.
You also know it because when
you drop an ice cube into a
glass of water, it doesn't sink
to the bottom, it floats
on the top.
You're so accustomed to seeing
that, but I want you to kind
of marvel at that the next
time you see it.
That the solid is actually less
dense then the liquid.
It's a very rare circumstance,
it's a very rare situation.
But it's very controlling in
the way ice works in the
climate system.
The fact that it floats on top
of the ocean, for example,
rather than sinking
to the bottom.
It changes everything in
terms of the way the
climate system works.
So a typical density for ice
is about 917 kilograms per
cubic meter.
Typical density for fresh
water is about 1,000.
Typical density for sea
water's about 1,025.
So this is less dense than both
of those, and would float
either in fresh water
or in seawater.
Any questions on that?
This is an interesting one.
If you've got a bucket of
seawater and you freeze it, or
start to freeze it, as the water
freezes, it'll expel
most of the salt.
So that if you take a chunk of
that ice that you formed and
melt it, the salinity is going
to be far less than the salt
water it was made from.
I'll give you an example.
If you start with a bucket of
ocean water with a salinity of
say, 35 parts per thousand, and
you froze it very slowly,
you could actually generate
ice that when melted had a
salinity of perhaps only
5 parts per thousand.
It really does expel most
of the salt when
you freeze that water.
And that plays a big role, as
you might imagine, in the way
the Arctic Ocean works.
When you form sea ice, the water
beneath it gets saltier
because you've expelled that
salt into the ocean.
The Inuit people know this.
When they're out travelling over
the sea ice hunting, if
they need water, well, you could
dig a hole through the
ice and get sea water to drink,
but humans cannot live
on seawater, it's too salty.
But they could knock
off a chunk of--
of course, the best thing would
be if there's snow.
If there's snow on top
of the ice, gather
that up and melt it.
That'll be fresh water.
But if there's no snow on the
ice, take a chunk of the sea
ice and melt it down and
you could live on that.
It's not very tasty, it's
brackish water, but you could
live on that because it's enough
fresher than the ocean
water was, that the human can
exist on that particular kind
of brackish water.
So this is important.
For climate purposes it's
important that ice and snow is
highly reflective of sunlight.
The typical albedo for
ocean water is
something less than 0.1.
It absorbs more than 90% of
the light that hits it.
On land, a more typical albedo
is something like .2, 0.2.
But yet for ice and snow, the
albedo is more like 0.8.
In other words, something like
80% of the radiation that hits
it is reflected back to space.
And that, as you can imagine,
albedos playing such an
important role in climate,
that's an important role for
ice controlling the albedo
of the surface.
And the last one I want to
mention is that ice, while we
think of it as something
brittle, when you take a chunk
of ice and hit it with a hammer,
it will shatter.
When it's under high enough
pressure it'll flow like a
liquid, like a viscous liquid.
And we'll talk about that when
it comes to how glaciers and
ice sheets move.
So review these and we'll start
on the description of
ice and the climate
system next time.